good morning John yesterday I let
everybody know that I was stuck in as
you say Cheyenne Wyoming I'm working on
my book because I'm stuck in book land I
haven't been thinking about what I'm
gonna do on vlog with it so I asked
everybody what I should talk about I'm
CT Peter I asked how in the world the
word Cheyenne this word is pronounced
like a girl named Anne who doesn't talk
very much because his brain sees that
word and just says nope that is not a
word that can be pronounced I can
understand that and it's probably for an
actual reason because the word Cheyenne
went through several rapid rounds of
what linguists call loan word adaptation
that's when speakers of one language
take award from another language and
then they modify the sounds in it so
that they can say it I didn't make it
pronounceable with the noises that their
language has English the loan word
adaptation of burrito is burrito because
we don't roll our arse just something
that every language does so in French
settlers were first learning about
people in the western United States they
asked the people that they had been
talking with who were Dakota about these
other people who were not Dakota and the
Dakota gave the French people their word
for those people who French people then
adapted that loanword into something
that sounded kind of like che N and then
somewhat rapidly English adapted that
loan word from French from chez en to
Cheyenne which sounds much more American
right and I say American because this
isn't just about languages it's about
dialects it's about the sounds that we
make like Cheyenne is not the kind of
noise that a British person would make
I'm sure they would find a much more
lovely way of saying that word no word
adaptation isn't a sign of disrespect
for a language it's a sign that we need
this word and we can't say it with the
noises that you make because we don't
have those noises anyway this video is
about stress and how to deal with it I
know that it doesn't seem like it here's
the situation when we experience like
existential threat so I'd still like our
being our identity our existence our
stress response is built for physical
threats and so our bodies do a bunch of
stuff to prepare us for a physical
threat they like our blood pressure goes
up our heart rate goes down sources get
diverted from our immune system and from
our digestion and we want to do one of
two things we want to fight or we want
to flee and the first two minutes of
this video
that was me fleeing that is an excellent
example of a bad but not worst strategy
because at least now I know stuff I
didn't know before if I'm thinking about
this like there's fight and there's
flight and flight is reading about
linguistics or going on
Facebook or whatever so what is fight
right like I can't punch my email inbox
that well certainly I would like to
sometimes a week ago I got a bunch of
bad news in a row and I was sitting
right here at this desk and I remember
thinking like that I had spent like half
an hour just trying to distract myself
and running away from this unpleasant it
was like a bunch of bad things unrelated
to each other so it was just like piling
on top of me right it didn't get better
until I interfaced with it and that
might be thinking about it or writing an
email or talking to somebody about it
but dealing with it letting it be in my
life that's the fight it's remarkable
kind of but thinking about the
unpleasantness makes the unpleasantness
so much less unpleasant but because it
is unpleasant you don't want to do it at
all when I send a bunch of emails and
the the fight was over and I had dealt
with it and I was through it and I
wasn't stressed out anymore I could play
with my baby and be happy I know this
isn't always possible
my worst stresses in my life have been
things that I can't fix that you can't
interface with they're just things that
happened because bad things happen that
just accept and that's no fun the other
things though the things that I can at
least affect in some way and it can be
hard to find the difference between
those two things I found that kind of
nothing works except like overpowering
my lizard brain and actually doing the
things that I know will help whether
that's exercise or contemplation or
talking to somebody about it not running
away to read it not learning about
linguistics interfacing with the thing
that is causing the stress and fighting
you know it's like the most unnatural of
ways like slowly and methodically and
with the knowledge that nothing is going
to fix this except work John I'll see
you on Tuesday